Follow lane,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange focus channel.
Uh,
my name is Paul.
Today's video is the third installment
in the mystery languages series.
Maybe you've seen mystery languages one
and two.
If not,
you can find them right here.
But here's how it works.
I'll play you a sample of a language and
then I'll show you a written sample of
the language and you can make an
educated guess as to what that language
is.
And don't worry if you can't get the
exact language correctly.
The important thing is that you tell us
your guesses and your reason for your
guesses in the comments down below.
And that will start a lot of interesting
discussions.
So let's get right into the first
language.
Please listen.
Yo,
Miss [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] it's
an example is [inaudible]. [inaudible]
was purse.
Now let's see some written samples of
that language.
Kwong Costa show.
This means how much is this Anisa
lovable.
This means where's the toilet bodily Mr
pocket boxes plow.
This means speak more slowly,
please.
[inaudible] this means could you write
it please?
So what language is it?
The language is Catalan,
a romance language spoken mostly in
eastern Spain as well as in Andorra and
in part of France.
If you guessed Spanish or Portuguese or
another romance language,
then you're not too far off.
In fact,
Katelyn has 85% lexical similarity with
Spanish,
but the two are only partly mutually
intelligible.
Catalan is part of the Occidental
Romance sub family along with oxytocin.
It's always interesting to take a look
at a romance language that you're not
too familiar with because you might see
some features of one romance language
and some different features from another
romance language.
If we look at the sentence again for
three area,
looks like the Spanish word for could
this word [inaudible].
It seems kind of like a clear in French
[inaudible] in Italian,
which mean to write.
And this phrase,
see you plow seems like silver plate in
front,
so you can see why some people say that
learning to romance languages helps you
understand a fair bit of the others,
at least in writing.
Okay.
Onto the next language.
Please listen.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
And again,
let's have a look at some written
samples in Gemini.
This means,
how are you when said to a male
[inaudible] work in decibels,
this means pleased to meet you.
Sim,
my no,
this means,
what is your name when said to a male
Aerosol Kaya to note,
and this means,
where are you from?
So what language is it?
The languages?
I'm Horic,
I'm horic is a language spoken in
Ethiopia by around 22 million people.
It's a member of the Semitic language
family,
meaning that it's related to Arabic and
Hebrew,
but it's not intelligible with those
languages.
I've studied Hebrew and Arabic in the
past,
but I can't understand.
I'm Arik at all.
But there are a couple of cognates I can
see in these written samples like the
word for name Sim in Arabic,
the word is Islam and in Hebrew it's
Shim here and I'm horic summer is your
name with the suffix being a possessive
pronoun.
In Arabic you'd say is muck and in
Hebrew you'd say a Shim Heart.
Also mum is the word for what?
Which might be related to the Arabic
word math and the Hebrew word mark.
Okay.
Onto the next language,
please listen.
Kiva Gosiger very challenging.
[inaudible] the unit mini van
[inaudible]
and again,
let's see some written samples of this
language.
This means pleased to meet you.
I'm going to [inaudible] this means
where are you from?
[inaudible]
this means long time.
No,
see [inaudible].
This means have a good journey.
So what languages it,
it's the Tamil language.
Tamil is the language spoken in southern
India as well as in Sri Lanka as well as
by Tamil communities overseas and places
like Malaysia.
And Singapore is a dravidian language,
which is unrelated to the Indo European
languages spoken in northern India.
Tamil has a long literary history
reaching back to around 2,600
years ago.
The temple script is an aggregator,
meaning a script in which consonants and
vowels are written together as units,
which can't be separated.
Come to think of it,
the [inaudible] script that we had a
glance at earlier is also an avid
reader.
Well,
I hope you had fun guessing today's
mystery languages.
Be sure to leave your guesses and your
reasons for your guesses in the comments
down below.
And I'm sure that that will start lots
of interesting discussions.
Be sure to follow lane,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
And I'd like to say thank you to all of
my patrion supporters,
especially these ones right here on the
screen for their continuous monthly
pledges.
Thank you very much and have a nice day.